Entre el Océano Pacífico y el Mar
Caribe, podemos decir que Colombia es algo
así como la puerta de entrada de
Sudamérica.
Y... ¿sabeis qué?
Todo esto esto es Colombia:
Las largas y animadas playas de Santa Marta,
el desierto de La Guajira o la inaccesible
Leticia, capital de la frondosa Amazonia colombiana.
Las islas de San Andrés y Providencia, puro
caribe colombiano.
El eje cafetero de Quindío, Caldas y Risaralda.
O, como no, las vibrantes ciudades de Medellín,
Cali, o Barranquilla.
Y...todo ello, claro, sin poder olvidarnos
de la histórica y orgullosa Cartagena o de
la frenética Bogotá, la gran capital del
país; que, amigos con su Candelaria, su Cerro
de Monserrate o los increíbles museos del
Oro y de Botero, te dejarán, literalmente,
con la boca abierta.
De verdad, no podemos extrañarnos de que
cada vez más guías turísticas sitúen a
Colombia como un destino… 100% obligatorio.
Porque amigos, y os lo digo por experiencia
propia, Colombia es un país diverso y con
ritmo, mucho ritmo.
Su calles, sus comercios, su gastronomía…esa
bandeja paisa...
De verdad, amigos de VisualPolitik, os doy
mi palabra, estoy deseando volver a Colombia.
Pero… como os podéis imaginar, este vídeo
no va de turismo; para nada.
(En Mayo de 2018 se celebrarán elecciones
presidenciales y el 7 de agosto este país
estrenará nuevo Presidente, porque el actual,
Juan Manuel Santos, ha cumplido ya el límite
de dos mandatos).
Pues, precisamente, como la etapa de Santos
ha entrado en su recta final, queremos, con
este vídeo, echar un vistazo a la Colombia
que deja a su sucesor, con sus luces y...
sus sombras.
LA COLOMBIA DE HOY
Apostador y gran jugador de Póquer, Juan
Manuel Santos forma parte de una de las familias
tradicionalmente más influyentes de Colombia.
(Su propio tío abuelo, Eduardo Santos, ya
fue presidente del país allá por finales
de la década de los 30; y su familia fue
durante décadas propietaria del diario
El Tiempo, el periódico más importante de Colombia,
¡casi nada!)
De hecho, el propio Juan Manuel Santos fue
durante mucho tiempo subdirector y columnista
de este periódico.
Vamos, que influencia, dinero y poder, a esta
familia nunca le ha faltado.
Pues bien, tras dos legislaturas, el pasado
7 de agosto de 2017 arrancó el último año
de Juan Manuel Santos como Presidente… y
la verdad sea dicha lo hace con unos niveles
de popularidad que están por los suelos.
Fijaos, a pesar de haber incluso ganado el
Premio Nobel de la Paz por el acuerdo con
las FARC, según los últimos estudios publicados
entre el 65% y el 75% de los colombianos desaprueban
su gestión.
Así que la pregunta es,
¿cómo diantres todo un nobel de la paz puede tener semejante grado de desaprobación?
(Bueno, puede que algo tenga que ver la controversia
sobre su compromiso claro de que el pueblo
colombiano tendría siempre la última palabra
en el acuerdo de paz con las FARC, algo que
cómo sabéis no fue del todo así.
Bueno… digamos que Santos se olvidó de
su palabra).
Pero... sobre todo, amigos, dejando de lado
este punto, si por algo es tan suspendido
por los colombianos es, por la marcha de la
economía.
Así es, durante la última década este “Puma
del Pacífico” llamado Colombia ha tenido
un crecimiento bastante potente y llegó a
convertirse en uno de los países de moda
de toda Latinoamérica.
Sin embargo, las cosas últimamente son un
poco distintas, por no decir bastante.
Atentos a este gráfico.
Hoy, amigos, Colombia se enfrenta a una situación
de….. desaceleración, casi de estancamiento.
Fijaos, el último dato de crecimiento conocido
refleja un crecimiento interanual sólo ligeramente
superior al 1% y la previsión para el conjunto
de 2017 no es mucho mejor…
“De acuerdo con cálculos de BBVA Research,
la economía colombiana crecería un 1,5%
en 2017”.
Como veis este no es precisamente un buen
dato, sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que
la mayor parte de los países más ricos están
creciendo más.
Estados Unidos, Canadá, España, Alemania,
Reino Unido… todos ellos crecerán más
que Colombia en 2017.
Y claro, se supone que cuando eres más pobre
tienes que crecer más… por eso de la convergencia.
¿No os parece?
Así que llegados a este punto la pregunta
es ¿Qué está pasando con Colombia?
Muchos culpan de esta situación a la caída
de los precios del petróleo y las materias
primas… y en cierto modo tienen algo de
razón, pero… con matices.
(Es verdad que en su momento de mayor apogeo,
en 2013, el petróleo llegó a representar
más del 50% de todas las exportaciones, más
del 30% de toda la inversión extranjera directa
y más del 20% de los ingresos públicos…)
pero... también es verdad que durante años,
gracias al elevado precio del petróleo, el
gobierno de Colombia ha disfrutado de más
recursos que nunca antes, recursos que podría
haber utilizado para impulsar una economía
productiva y competitiva más allá de las
materias primas.
Y esto es algo que no parece que el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos haya sido capaz de hacer,
tal vez por haber estado centrado casi en
exclusiva en el acuerdo con las FARC.
En fin veamos cuales siguen siendo a día
de hoy los principales puntos débiles de
la economía colombiana.
EL DESASTRE DE LAS INFRAESTRUCTURAS
Durante años Colombia ha sido… como decirlo…
casi como un estado fallido en muchas zonas
de sus territorio.
Zonas que eran controladas por auténticos
señores de la guerra: guerrillas, paramilitares
y narcos.
Así que imaginad lo difícil que puede llegar
a ser gestionar un país así y lo difícil
que resulta construir infraestructuras.
Ahora bien, no os penseis que es solo esto,
para nada.
La verdad es que las infraestructuras nunca
han sido una gran prioridad para los diferentes
gobiernos colombianos… y el resultado de
todo ello ha sido... terrible.
Hoy la infraestructuras de Colombia son francamente
malas,
y con carencias de todo tipo.
¿El resultado?
Atentos a los datos porque os van a sorprender.
(Mover un contenedor de mercancías por el
interior del país es el doble de caro que
hacerlo en México o Bolivia y casi 4 veces
más caro que en Argentina, Chile o Perú.
De hecho la situación es tan desastrosa que
el transporte de mercancías entre el puerto
colombiano de Buenaventura y Bogotá es casi
3 veces más caro que llevar la misma carga
de Róterdam a Frankfurt.
Bueno, es más, es que según algunos cálculos
enviar un contenedor desde el puerto de Cartagena
a Bogotá cuesta el triple que enviarlo desde
la propia Cartagena a ¡Shanghai!
Ya os podéis hacer una idea de todas las
implicaciones que esto tiene para los costes
de suministro, los precios y la competitividad
de las empresas colombianas.
“En el último reporte, de todos los países
que seguimos según los costos de exportar
un contenedor, Colombia es el tercero más
costoso del mundo, luego de Venezuela y Rusia”
Por esto, el propio Juan Manuel Santos fijó
en 2010 como su prioridad número 1 cambiar
esta realidad.
Y es verdad, su gobierno acaba de lanzar
el mayor plan de infraestructuras de la historia
de Colombia.
Un plan con cofinanciación privada
y bajo un sistema de concesiones bastante
atractivo.
Sí, el plan parece bien diseñado pero, amigos…
tras 7 años llega con cierto retraso y muchos
problemas.
Es decir, a decir verdad en su casi 2 legislaturas,
los logros de Santos no son han sido todo
lo bueno que prometió iban a ser.
BUROCRACIA E IMPUESTOS
Tanto el Foro Económico Mundial como el Banco
Mundial afirman que Colombia es uno de los
países del mundo con impuestos más altos
a las empresas…
lo que evidentemente no es algo que ayude
a que estas crezcan y se desarrollen.
Mirad, según el informe “pagando impuestos”
que cada año publica PWC
La suma de todas
las cargas fiscales a las que se enfrenta
una empresa colombiana suponen el 69,8% de
todo su beneficio antes de todos los impuestos.
Porque, recordad que las empresas pagan más
impuestos además del impuesto sobre beneficios.
¡Casi el 70%!
Mucho más que en países como Alemania, España,
Estados Unidos… ¡Una locura!
Y respecto a la burocracia, pues tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo.
Un día en un siguiente vídeo tendríamos
que analizar la afición latinoamericana por
la burocracia, porque tiene miga.
(El caso es que en Colombia de media se emiten
al día alrededor de 15 normas y 3 decretos…
Y no solo eso, según un estudio realizado
por Universidad de La Sabana más del 30%
de todas las leyes aprobadas son inútiles
y solo generan costes a la sociedad).
¿Y qué ha hecho Juan Manuel Santos sobre
todas estas cuestiones?
Pues prácticamente nada, incluso ha empeorado
el escenario de salida.
LA VIOLENCIA PERSISTENTE
Es verdad que muchas ámbitos relacionados
con la seguridad están mejorando en Colombia.
Y buen reflejo de ello es lo que está ocurriendo,
por ejemplo, en el sector turístico.
En 2016 algo más de 5 millones de turistas
visitaron este país, más del doble que en
2010 y casi 10 veces más que en el año 2000.
No está mal ¿Verdad?
(Sin embargo, a pesar de ello, en muchas zonas
del país la situación no está mejorando.
Según Naciones Unidas y también el Centro
de Recursos para el Análisis de Conflictos,
la violencia persiste en las zonas del país
más afectadas, sin que el acuerdo con las
FARC haya mejorado sustancialmente la situación).
De hecho, amigos, por ejemplo, la producción
de coca y también de cocaína se encuentra
hoy en su máximo histórico.
Prestad atención a este gráfico:
Pero… puede que os estéis preguntando ¿Cómo
es posible que los niveles de violencia y
de producción de sustancias ilícitas no
se hayan reducido tras el acuerdo del gobierno
con las FARC?
Bueno, primero porque a pesar de toda la campaña
del gobierno la violencia de las FARC era
enorme, pero suponía menos del 10% de toda
la violencia nacional.
Y además, de donde las FARC se ha marchado,
su presencia ha sido suplida no por las instituciones
sino en muchos casos por otros grupos mafiosos
o de narcos.
En muchos casos de mutuo acuerdo con antiguos
mandos de las FARC..
Al fin y al cabo, amigos, el negocio sigue
siendo muy lucrativo.
Lo dijimos aquí en VisualPolitik, el acuerdo
con las FARC dejaba muchas cosas en el aire.
Y por todo esto, el llamado “dividendo de
la paz” no está siendo tan grande como
el prometido por el gobierno.
Pero… seamos justos, no todo ha sido malo
o regular en el gobierno de Santos.
LA MEJOR CARA DE LA ADMINISTRACIÓN SANTOS
Hay que reconocer que el gobierno de Santos
también ha tenido algunos logros:
Juan Manuel Santos incorporó a Colombia a
la Alianza del Pacífico, cuyo éxito ya nos
contó aquí Alberto en un pasado vídeo.
Y desde luego, la política exterior ha sido
el campo donde más fuerta ha sido este gobierno.
Hoy Colombia está mucho más abierta al exterior
que en la etapa anterior a Santos.
Hablamos de comercio, de visados, de relaciones,
etc.
Junto a ello la pobreza se ha reducido bastante
y el país ha captado mucha inversión extranjera.
Son logros destacados,
pero aun con todo, mi impresión es que la
llegada de un nuevo gobierno puede ser una
buena noticia para Colombia.
Cuando Juan Manuel Santos llegó a la Casa
de Nariño el país parecía encontrarse listo
para abordar un proceso de transformación
completo, y los recursos petroleros estaban
ahí para pagar la factura.
Sin embargo, esto no se ha conseguido.
Muy al contrario, Santos dejará una Colombia
con una situación económica débil y muchos
más proyectos de futuro, que realidades en
el presente.
En fin, turno para tí, ¿Cómo valoras a
Santos?
¿Si tuvieras que poner nota a su gestión cómo la calificarías?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo no
dudes en darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho.
Por cierto, Chile también está a las puertas
de un cambio de gobierno, si quieres conocer
cómo le ha ido bajo la presidencia de Michelle
Bachelet no te pierdas este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.